how's Gomez my name is Pierre this game
just came out it's called how to full
boyfriend also known as Cajun boyfriend
simulator it is exactly what it sounds
like
so cry play this two years ago and I saw
him played then and I was like that
looks hilarious but I don't want to copy
him haha so now they made a remake of it
two years later and I'm really curious
to check it out cuz this it's too
ridiculous to be a thing right this is
just insane I did play a similar game
called like I don't know what it was
called but you had a dinosaur as a
girlfriend or something
[ __ ] was weird man but this is I expect
this to medium wiener so let's fire this
bad boy up cenk PG Nations Institute
welcome to st. Padilla Nations please
enter your name
I can't type what the [ __ ] enter your
first name oh there we go okay
hey Yoko that probably means pigeon in
Japanese or Suncheon I don't know if you
know tell me I wish we knew myself oh
yeah who the Chan I goddamn it put pure
Chan L do oh come on and the PI oh [ __ ]
there we go it's PewDiePie okay ah sure
uh hopefully this one have like a giant
effect yes it is goddamnit this is no
this is actually like a same engine
originally I don't know if they yeah
they probably made it as all those RPG
Maker all those horror games that I
usually play how about boyfriend
includes apart from Lucilla every slash
station model allowing even the birdie
as a barrister Paris normal human when
first introduced okay display human
portraits will this yes is this
essential or this is so weird already
[ __ ] bit myself and it hurts when I
talk it sank pigeon nations a school
blessed with extensive curricula and
facilities it's already been a year
since I had my own near life and walk
through these gates I should probably
say the school is known for one thing in
particular let me guess it only contains
pigeons
this school is Japanese no the world's
greatest gathering place for gifted
birds oh it's a birds in general birds
who wants to study the arts the
scientists if it's part of all all come
to st. Peter Nations I don't know birds
can do light this is news to me
the teaching staff and student body are
both made up diverse blend of birds of
different backgrounds and species I'm
often asked why I choose to come here
despite not being a parent what a twist
so what I am I can't wait to find out
it's a long story though I'm so
intrigued not every day I see you
rushing along like this who said that
oh that's me I look like that now that
doesn't make sense
that's Ryota okay Ryota usually you'd
been ready for an hour by now pew chen
overslept that's us now that's her okay
okay I don't know if that's a boy or
girl name it looks like it's Japanese I
can't tell this rock dub it's named
Kabara Ryoga you've been friends since
he was barely hatched oh gee pan what am
I supposed to say here he can be a
little mischievous but he's responsible
and caring well he looks like it his eye
color changed that's a breakfast that's
a detail they missed breakfast was a
little hard to catch today I can't relax
without red meat inside Ryota living as
a hunter gatherer sounds tough I'd be
happy to make you breakfast you know hmm
so are we like a tiger or some [ __ ] I
might take you up on that offer
whence starvation looms thanks Ryoga ah
school bell oh the Bell is already come
on we need to hurry to class jeepers no
good being late on the first day jeepers
indeed Bruce jeepers indeed I don't know
why you Bruce but I'm pretty damn pulled
into this universe and so Bri you would
have pulled me along into the school I
don't know how a pigeon would do that
but today is the start of a new semester
II I wonder what licensed all it was all
I could do to adjust it to the adversary
last year
better make up for all that lost fun and
there we go hard to fall boyfriend I
love this stock imagery of just [ __ ]
pigeons the most blended and greatest
academy of the pigeon by the pigeon and
for the pigeon that's the best [ __ ]
slogan I ever heard in my life
first term oh god I am this song will
never stick and gets and will never get
sick of this song god damn it what is
wrong with me this is now my new theme
for all my videos I think when two three
Ryoga and I are in the same class again
old faces new faces shouldn't be old
pecks ah a strange thrill fills my heart
as I look around at the assembled men
I'm assembled birds I hope we can all
can get it I hope we all get along
history the formation of many happy
memories
oh the teachers here oh she's so [ __ ]
Sugoi good morning everybody
the bird puns are here already
fantastic err I'm Nana Kiko zoo yaki I
seem to be your teacher this year I
specialize in math and physics and also
my favorite two subjects and also some
other things that's also my favorite I
wonder what I mean or she and inside
she's a what is it called
she fell asleep he falls it sir wake up
it's homeroom he sleeps with his eyes
open I guess birds do that right i'm
sokka way sorry my my we Abhijit we just
took over this quail is Nanaki Kazu yaki
he is famously soft forensic math
professor okay so that's what it is I
heard rumors are the rumors but I hadn't
expected him to fall asleep just like
that apparently he's a well known as a
mathematician just goes to show great
minds coming out forms
I thought pigeon brains were really tiny
bit ah I'm sorry
is it a little while man hey which
reminds me we have a trend for student
please introduce yourself she regarding
[ __ ] God
what's the point I have no wish to speak
with come owners do not think I'm here
because I wish to be oh my god she's
like the rich upper-class ass ass pigeon
oh well I guess that's but side hey hey
that's no good but he doesn't want to
introduce himself oh it's a boy are all
the pigeon boys in this game the system
will collapse and we'll all turn into
cool acts and descenders well when you
put it like that could you at least say
your name she regarding all you just
said it
ah Shara Garnett LaBelle Sakura yah boo
boo that's my bird impression sorry I'll
never do that again
oh my god holy [ __ ] his fat as [ __ ] it
seems it's fan chalice shigani Sakuya
his feathers would make anybody proud
they are quite ps-aguié
and quite luscious it's pretty stuck up
but then transferring is never easy I
hope we can be friends I think this guy
has sent by potential mother your breath
stink Sakuya sits down glaring daggers
and reordain me Hey
that was a peck Adam I'll stop with the
bird impressions I think this little
bread is telling me that there's going
to be trouble down the line
oh the puns the puns lunch already
today is slipping by so quickly that
reminds me I had this books out from my
from the library all summer I'll return
them now we're gonna run into the the
horse what do you call it English
bookworm oh yeah you called bookworm in
Sweden we say study horse I don't know
if you had the same what is everyone
aside from the receptionist there's
hardly anybody he anybody any birdie
it's someone looking at me probably just
my imagination or not a mourning dove
stand in a dark corner staring at my
direction so cute sakya morning devs
aren't very common in Japan but
apparently they they're everywhere in
America Pierre Chen and did you want
something from me
he looked away not really and Gary's
looking at me like I'm stupid I'm I'm
pretty sure it was him who felt I felt
looking at me there's no one else here
are you sure yes I don't want anything
to do with you it's the things you're
carrying that I'm interested in he
glances at the desk as if to say hurry
up and return them already
oh sorry are they always do this back
hat like I don't know Japanese there
were a little too dense and I never
finished him were you waiting for them
all summer he silently returns his gaze
to his books maybe he's in a bad mood
I'm type I pew chant a sophomore what
about you
oh yeah that's what first that's a grade
in school right I don't
you're not geeky Fujiki arrow nageki
freshman so sophomore in his second year
it's just still a boy I mean it's
nothing wrong with that but okay
mourning doves a pretty range of it
maybe it's just his voice but he seems
kinda sad I wish I didn't change the eye
color it ruins the immersion in this
great fantastic game leaving it alone
he's reading his book again okay sorry
to bother you what
burly [ __ ] I keep meeting depressed
people today now that now that I have
that out of the way I think I'll head
back to class
oh wait isn't that oh that's them again
Sakuya she should have been instructed
not to approach me in school Yuya come I
said oh yeah what kind of thing is that
to say to you old bredren after a good
day my brother he must be joking you've
never once been branded to me please
don't try and talk to me again I know
time I've no time for half-breeds
[ __ ] music I'll be going now
hey wait you're just it I love the
walking sound of thing wow they really
put effort into this remake I guess I
guess even if we're in the same school
now what's done is dang I hadn't meant
to eavesdrop but I think I just
overheard something juicy the
ever-popular trendsetter ladies man
sokka's sake Yuya is Sakas Suk sakuya's
brother I wonder with the what did I
wonder what the story behind that is hey
you heard that little thing wait are you
friend of second.you yeah I'm a mom I'm
sorry sorry am i doing good with voices
I think I am thank you by the way how do
you mean - listen you
oh no sweet I try to stay sexy and slave
in front of all your little ladies but
that there wasn't too cool oh my god
I'm the lady this is weird for me
oh that's why it's hatoful boyfriend I'm
so stupid I'm sorry there we go this
explains everything
I'm really curious what animal light we
are oh my God he's so cute
shock shot I ship astute so much this
fantail pigeon is Sakai is son sakazaki
yuya's an upperclassman oh my god I
never talked to him before but he's
famous and I'm totally fangirling sorry
I just thought I'd say what do you think
right throughout the school everybody
knows everything
you're pitching me how did you I know
everybody here beside you're the only
human also we are humans okay
they didn't there we go a single puppy
in a field of rye did you say you were a
friend of Sakura's I just imagine them
going in these giant doors and I'm like
the only human and they're all down
there on the floor like it's not exactly
by weight we had rather ballistic
introduction this morning we're in the
same class battle I never have thought
that stuck-up aristocrat wannabe was
your brother aristocrat wannabe
here's an aristocrat actually the
genuine article
in the flesh yes it's a bit of a pain so
good luck Mon Ami ad yay what the [ __ ]
he really is a noble bird I never heard
anything of like that about you yet Oh
probably a twisty business my cheeks are
getting plushy or just thinking about it
second class started Oh school finish
okay that that's all for today sigh safe
everyone yay huh sir wait Ryota he said
I was going through the infirmary maybe
you should go and see if it's still
there
infirmary now that I think about it
Ryota always did have a weak stomach I
should go to the infirmary just to make
sure he's okay
my god maybe something dirty will happen
I love the medicine that's is fantastic
excuse me nobody's here they just loved
that pond don't they there's no one
nobody sleeping behind the curtains and
the doctor isn't here hi then my
hunter-gathering sick filled no presents
there's nobody here Ryota no reply
infirmary is empty wait did he go home
already I feel a little nervous poking
around the empty room now that I think
of it I haven't been here much before
unlike Ryota I'm perfectly healthy well
they've got all kinds of drugs in here
if Phil party fare lucio and benzene
what do these even do can't find out
whoa did it it it it ended an octave
what the [ __ ] Shu video is so sir things
if the date what you might now know
thank you
Oh what the [ __ ] we got the creepy the
creepy one here I like the song there
dead dead dead dead and then Tenten this
patches is a bomb out here were mean
eschew the school doctor I love the
detail with the glasses he's rather
creeping person he had a bad reputation
along the student body everybody knows
that even just talking to him can bring
you down with asparagus this psittacosis
or even worse things and I even heard
him come in the door I didn't even hear
and I never heard him come in the door
ninja doctor all the sad I'm let me know
you don't look like you have a good
reason to be here
did you need something um I heard Rio de
kabaah Kawara from two-three was
supposed to be here him he's already
gone oh why didn't I come fine why
didn't he come find me before going home
sorry to bother you I'll be going now
oh my god I'm so scared ah finally out
of that den of evil
Ryota has already gone home what do I do
now oh I never got around joining a club
last year maybe I'll go and take a look
in some my options
I think there are clubs for baseball
soccer track kendo migration
bird-watching bird-watching wasn't that
another one anyway
I'll start with a track team I ran in
middle school and it's always funny
watching the birds buffer run oh man
that's okay I think the club room is on
the ground floor of this to the side a
white dove is having a tantrum outside
Oh God
cuckoo there's no pudding for a man Oh
orcas and rejects it it's a lie a
vicious failsafe action he's dancing
around and squished on a squished
pudding hey that's not very nice to do
to the pudding what is going on oh god
what the hell is that
what why is this picture like that this
is oxen he doesn't really look it but
supposedly he's a faint tail pigeon I
think what does that mean either way
he's hyper cool oh so he's actually a
pigeon okasan has suffered a deception
most vile of wretched betrayal betrayal
cool so that's what he means by saying
it I am a loss low orcs an introduction
in truth in truck instructed that
parting be provided for new members cool
but this is no padding Elstad scorned
betrayed dragged into the streets and
shut by those he trusted most its
squished and filthy but the thing under
his feet looks like normal store-bought
pudding what's wrong with it sir cool
cool
spare the jets young lady okasan use
wing attack it's super oh what a
wonderful pokemon reference they'll rue
the day they crossed oak ocean he'll
have them flayed hanged shut at dawn he
well it's my favorite character so far
this is brilliant kuru oaks and must now
train to achieve true pudding fatty well
and he's gone he's a good runner but
what is pudding I have to do with track
team that's what I asked myself every
day good just left I don't even know he
could open the door this is amazing
and so ended the first day of my second
semester at sank pigeon nations
beautiful let's do a save there I love
this game this is probably the best game
I played in I can't even remember how
long and I think he bros like it to go
ahead and leave a comment
via twitter hashtag i live in the
description I do appreciate your board's
feedback I wouldn't be doing this
without it so I appreciate you bros
going the extra mile to do that on
Twitter that's very cool of you and if
not that's fine
like if you're a silent watcher you're
still watching my videos and I
appreciate you regardless of that so
don't get me wrong with all this and
then yeah anyway that said that's all
for me for now I hope you bros enjoyed
this video if you did thank you for
leaving a like and I'll see you in the
next one let me know if you want more I
will gladly do more that's all stay
awesome bros